ولم تقم الصين في أي وقت خلال
هذه الحرب بإدانة الغزو الروسي
لأوكرانيا ، فهم لا يزالون مشترًا ضخمًا
للنفط الروسي يساعد في تمويل كل هذا ، وقد
حذر جون كيربي هنا في الولايات المتحدة من البيت الأبيض  ضد هو إذا
كانت الصين ستخرج بعد هذه الزيارة
إيفان
وتقول حسنًا أنه يجب أن يكون هناك اتفاق سلام في
الوقت الحالي لن يكون مستساغًا من قبل
أوكرانيا في الغرب نظرًا لأن روسيا
قد استولت على المزيد من الأراضي مما كانت عليه عندما بدأ كل هذا
أكيدًا وأعلنت ذلك  إنها
تقوم بضم الأراضي الأوكرانية التي تم الاستيلاء عليها
منذ الغزو العام الماضي ،
وللتأكيد على أن فلاديمير
بوتين كان يوم السبت جديدًا من
مذكرة التوقيف الصادرة عن المحكمة الجنائية الدولية بزيارة
مدينة ماريوبول الأوكرانية المحتلة من روسيا ،
حيث يقول الكرملين إنه هبط
بطائرة هليكوبتر قادها بنفسه.  في
ضواحي تلك المدينة المحطمة
وزارت مبنى سكنيًا شيدته
الحكومة الروسية للتو أثناء
لقائه مع بعض السكان هناك
الخشخاش ، تسمع صوتًا بعيدًا عن الكاميرا
يقول اللغويون لدينا أن أحدهم كان يصرخ ،
هذا كله عرض ، هذا ليس صحيحًا هذه
المرة  في العام الماضي حاصر الجيش الروسي
تلك المدينة وكان يقصفها
من البر والبحر والجو ودمر الكثير
منها ، وكنت أقابل السكان الذين
كانوا يفرون ووصفوا قضاء
أسابيع تحت القصف بالرعب والاختباء
في الأقبية التي دفن الجيران الذين قتلوا
على يد المدفعية الروسية في الداخل.
الساحات الأمامية لمباني شقتهم
وتحدثت إلى إحدى النساء اللواتي التقيت بهن
قبل عام وهربت من أنها تعيش ، وقالت إنها
لاجئة في الخارج ، قالت إن رؤية
فلاديمير بوتين في مسقط رأسها يشبه
رؤية قاتل متسلسل يعود إلى
مسرح الجريمة